Guten Abend, Karakulak ist mein Name und ich bin der diensthabende Arzt auf dieser Station und würde
gerne das Arztname geschickt mit den Tieren führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja natürlich. Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir. Also wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Rosvita Hagen. Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Ja, Rosvita R-O-S-W-I-T-H-A und Hagen H-A-G-E-N.
Also Frau Hagen. Ja, genau.
Sie? Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 61. 61. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 18. Mai 63.
63. Okay. Und wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind zur Zeit?
Ja, man wächst ja nicht mehr in meinem Alter. Ich bin 1,63 m.
1,63 m. Wissen Sie, wie viel wiegen Sie zur Zeit?
Ja leider, ja 80 kg wiegen ich.
Okay. Also Frau Hagen, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ach, ich habe solche heftigen Schmerzen im Bauch.
Und das hat heute Vormittag angefangen und ich kann mich kaum halten.
Das krampft sich alles zusammen und ich habe also so heftige Schmerzen.
Ich habe das überhaupt noch nicht erlebt.
Ich habe mich auch schon dreimal übergeben müssen.
Und mir ist unglaublich schlecht.
Und dabei hat der Tag eigentlich schön angefangen.
Wir haben heute Morgen ein Sekt empfangen in der Kanzlei von meinem Mann.
Und es gab eben Sekt und Häppchen und Lachs und Cannabis.
Und ich darf gar nicht dran denken.
Jetzt ist mir so schlecht und die Aufschmerzen sind sehr, sehr stark.
Ja.
Okay, also Frau Hagen, ich habe nicht gut verstanden.
Entschuldigung, Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie Cannabis oder so etwas gesagt?
Oder?
Ja, Cannates.
Da sind so kleine, kleine belegte Brote mit Ei und Kaviar und weichen Käse und Gürtchen.
Also so schön belegte Brötchen.
Ja, also nach dem Verzicht von diesen Kekse oder?
Ja, ich glaube vorallem der Fisch.
Also ich darf an den Fisch überhaupt nicht denken.
Ja, da war eben Lachs dabei, Rohrlachs und so Sushi-Röhrchen waren auch dabei.
Okay, uuuh, jetzt ist mir so schlecht.
Nach dem Verzicht von diesem Sushi so etwas haben die Beschwerden begonnen, oder?
Ja, also eine Stunde hinterher ungefähr, ja.
Stunde hinterher.
Okay, können Sie uns wieder genau beschreiben, wo die Schmerzigen genau ist?
Die Schmerzen, die sitzen, also hier, also im oberen Teil vom Bauch, also ich würde sagen oberhalb vom Bauchnabel.
Und was ganz merkwürdig ist, ich habe das Gefühl, das strahlt bis in die rechte Schulter hier so hoch.
Okay, die Schulter.
Okay, könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskalap bewerten, wobei ein sehr leichter und sehr starker Schmerzen bedeutet.
Wie stark Ihre Schmerzen sind.
Also das sind wirklich sehr, sehr heftige Schmerzen.
Also, Zehen sind die nicht, also ist ja nicht der Kopf abgefallen, aber so bei acht bis neun würde ich die schon einschätzen, ja.
Okay, also soll ich Ihnen etwas geben?
Oh, das wäre gut, ja, damit ich das besser aushalten kann, ja.
Okay, aber ob ich Ihnen etwas gebe, dann möchte ich gerne wissen, ob Sie irgendwelche Allergien haben.
Allergien? Ich habe nur so eine Kontaktallergie gegen Nickel, das weiß ich.
Aber Medikamenten haben Sie keine Allergien.
Bei Medikamenten habe ich noch nie Probleme gehabt.
Super, okay.
Dann lege ich Ihnen einen Zugang und dann gebe ich Ihnen die Schmerzen.
Das wird mich erleichtern, ja.
Okay, jetzt kommen wir wieder Ihre Beschwerden zurück.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie kramfartig? Sie haben kramfartig, oder?
Ja, ja, ja, also, ob sich das alles zusammenzieht, ja.
Und dann lässt das wieder so ein bisschen nach und dann fängt es wieder an, ja.
Okay, kramfartig, okay.
Und Sie haben dreimal Erbruch, Erbrechen.
Ja, ja.
Wie sah das Erbruch nachaus?
Das war natürlich genau das Zeug, was ich vorher gegessen hatte, ja.
Essenwäste, meine Sie.
Ja, Essenwäste, okay.
Und fühlen Sie Sie fiebrig oder haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, also Fieber würde ich jetzt nicht drauf kommen.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht fiebrig.
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ja, ich habe schon länger mal, also in letzt,
ja, das habe ich schon ziemlich lange jetzt eigentlich,
dass ich häufiger mal Durchfall habe, aber habe ich mir eigentlich nix bei gedacht, ja.
Okay, aber gibt es nicht etwas Besonderes dieses Mal, oder?
Nee, also jetzt ist mir das nicht aufgefallen.
Nee, okay.
Ja.
Und haben Sie es so brennen auch?
Sod brennen, nee, Sod brennen eigentlich nicht nur, also dieses übliche Nachdem übergeben,
dass das halt so kratzt im Hals, ne?
Okay, verstehe.
Nach dem Erbrechen.
Okay.
Ja.
Und jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu diese, diese Essen, also was und wie gegessen haben.
Was enthält dieses Essen, also Fisch und?
Es war roher Fisch, scheit, ne?
Geräuchter Fisch und Rohrfisch.
Ja.
Und Schinken und Käse und Kaviar und so, ja, kleine Tomaten und Gürkchen und so was.
Hat jemand, der diese Essen schon gegessen hat, hat auch dieses Problem, was sie haben?
Oh, ich weiß das natürlich nicht.
Ich bin ja jetzt, ich bin dann ja nach Hause gegangen und also mein Mann zum Beispiel hat nichts gehabt, ja.
Ja, das ist nicht.
Er hat das Gleichzeug gegessen, ja.
Nee, okay.
Und ja, jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu ihr allgemeinzustand.
Schlafen Sie gut, Bauagen?
Normalerweise schlafe ich eigentlich gut, ja doch, würde ich sagen, ich schlafe eigentlich immer gut.
Okay.
Und jetzt haben Sie Apathetlosigkeit oder kaum Apathetlosigkeit?
Ja, ich darf von Essen überhaupt nicht denken, ja.
Verstehe.
Ja.
Jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu jeder Krankenfolge stelle.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche konischeren Krankenkunden bekannt, wie Skokrankheit,
Bluthochdruck, Schildröse, Untergrund?
Ich war eigentlich immer kerngesund, das Einzige, was ich mal hatte und das waren eben
Miome in der Gebärmutter und deswegen hat man dann schon vor zehn Jahren die Gebärmutter entfernt.
Okay.
Also ich dokumentiere alles, was Sie erwähnen haben, deswegen ich bitte Sie ein bisschen etwas
geduld.
Ja, klar.
Okay.
Und außer diese Operation haben, wurden Sie schon noch operiert?
Ja, als Kind habe ich mal die Mandeln rausbekommen, ja.
Wie alt waren Sie damals?
Ja, ich war so in der dritten vierten Klasse.
Hier muss ungefähr zehn gewesen sein.
Okay, zehn Jahre.
Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein, Bauchhaken?
Nein, eigentlich brauche ich nie Tabletten.
Das Einzige, was ich nehme, ich habe manchmal so ein bisschen Wadenkremse, ich nehme halt
so so Nahrungsergänzung, so ein bisschen Magnesium.
Aber sonst brauche ich eigentlich nie Tabletten.
Okay.
Haben Sie also gegen diese Bauchschmerzen etwas eingenommen?
Ach, bin ich gar nicht zugekommen, ja.
Das ging ja jetzt sofort los und danach war mir so schlecht, da konnte ich gar keine Medikamente
einnehmen.
Okay, aber sind Sie schon beim Aufhaus das gewesen?
Nein, nein, ich bin direkt hierher gekommen, weil es mir so furchtbar schlecht ging.
Okay.
Und Sie haben eventuell, dass Sie gegen Nikkele Allergien haben?
Ist jetzt sie sich?
Ja, also wenn ich da Hautkontakt habe, dann kriege ich halt so rote, schuppige Stellen
und die Haut wird so rissig und nässt, wenn ich das nicht abstelle, ja.
Okay, verstehe.
Außer diese Nikkele Allergien haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien auch?
Ja, also nicht, dass ich wüsste, ich bin eigentlich so ein gesunder Mensch, ja.
Und jetzt ein paar Fragen, ich habe eine Einfache zu jeder Lebensgewohnheit.
Rauchen Sie Frau Hagen?
Nein, ich rauchte tatsächlich überhaupt nicht, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Okay, super.
Okay.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, das mache ich allerdings schon, ja.
Ich trinke sehr gerne mal ein Glas Sekt oder ein Glas trockenen Weißwein, ja.
Also das ist schon ziemlich regelmäßig, ja.
Okay, also wie viel trinken Sie?
Ach, bestimmt zwei bis drei Mal in der Woche ein bis zwei Gläser Sekt, ja.
Ein bis zwei Gläser Sekt.
Also das ist mir jetzt bestimmt nicht schlecht bekommen, kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Okay.
Und die nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage Frau Hagen.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Rauchen?
Ach, nee, nee, nee, also wirklich nicht, nein.
Und sind Sie vorständig geimpft?
Sowohl gegen Kinderkrankheiten als auch gegen Corona?
Kinderkrankheit, da liegt ja schon eine Weile zurück.
Aber gegen Corona bin ich natürlich geimpft, ja, klar.
Wie viel Mal?
Auch jetzt insgesamt vier Mal.
Und zur Grippeimpfung gehe ich auch immer jedes Jahr.
Okay, sehr, sehr.
Und besuchen Sie Ihre Frauen als erstin regelmäßig Frau Hagen?
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Also obwohl die Gebärmutter raus ist, muss man ja trotzdem immer nach dem Rechten gucken, ja.
Jeder gehe schon regelmäßig zur Grippsversorgung.
Wann war das letzte Untersuchung?
Ach, im Frühjahr jetzt, diesen Jahres.
War alles in Ordnung?
Ja, ja, klar.
Bei mir ist immer alles in Ordnung gewesen, nur jetzt geht es mir so schlecht, ja.
Okay.
Und jetzt möchte ich einfach fragen, so Ihre Familie stellen.
Haben Ihre Eltern noch Frau Hagen?
Ja, also, die leben beide noch, ja, ja.
Die sind natürlich schon hoch betagt, ja.
Und leiden Sie Ihre Eltern an chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, meine Mutter hat halt diesen typischen Alterszucker, ja.
Und sie muss dann eben ihre Medikamente nehmen.
Aber so besondere Diät hält sie überhaupt nicht.
Sie nimmt halt nur diese Tabletten.
Und mein Vater, naja, gut, dem geht es nicht so gut.
Die beiden leben inzwischen in einem alten Heim.
Und er hatte einen Schlaganfall und ist seitdem auch den Rollstuhl angewiesen.
Aber er ist eben, die gesagt ja auch schon, über 90 Jahre.
Ah, verstehe, okay, ja.
Haben Sie Geschwister, Frau Hagen?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und was machen Sie beruflich, Frau Hagen?
Ja, ich arbeite in einer Kunstgalerie.
Kunstgalerie?
Mhm.
Kunstler oder?
Bitte?
Sie sind Kunstler oder?
Nein, ich arbeite nur in der Galerie.
Also ich begrüße die Besucher und vermitle neue Kunstler
und schick die Arbeiten wieder zurück,
wenn die ihre Ausstellung beenden und solche Sachen.
Ja, haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Stress?
Ich weiß nicht, das ist eine sehr schöne Arbeit.
Ich habe hier immer nur mit schönen Dingen zu tun.
Hast du es?
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Frau Hagen?
Ja, Sie haben in der Kunstgalerie.
Ja, klar.
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Töchter, aber die sind natürlich schon groß.
Sind Sie gesund?
Okay.
Ja.
Jetzt möchte ich zurück zu Beschwerden kommen.
Haben Sie Farbeveränderung in Ihrer Stuhl gemerkt?
Prober Stuhl?
Ja, Farbeveränderung, vielleicht heller geworden.
Das ist mir nicht so aufgefallen.
Aber was mir aufgefallen ist,
dass der Urin in letzter Zeit ziemlich dunkel ist.
Dunkeler als früher.
Ich habe schon gedacht, ob ich nicht genug trinke,
aber eigentlich trinke ich ganz gut.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie das bemerkt?
Schon mehrere Wochen.
Normalerweise sieht man das gar nicht,
aber wenn man in einer besonderen Toilette ist,
wo man das sehen kann,
dann ist es nicht so, dass man das nicht mehr aufgefallen hat.
Okay, verstehe.
Ja, also Frau Hagen.
Meine Seite habe ich alle Fragen gestellt.
Fällt Ihnen etwas ein, das ich wissen sollte?
Eigentlich habe ich Ihnen alles erzählt.
Sie haben mir auch alles gefragt,
auch zu dem Essen heute.
Wie gesagt, ich war immer ganz gesund.
Und das hat mich jetzt so ein bisschen verschreckt.
Ja, diese Affäre, weil die Schmerzen auch so sehr stark waren.
Und Sie haben auch eventuell,
das ist die erste Mal passiert.
Ja, sowas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay.
Ja, also Frau Hagen,
auf der anonymystischen Angabe,
ich habe mich von einer,
entweder eine Galenblasen-Entzündung
oder Galenstein kann auch sein.
Oder ja.
Aber dagegen kann man noch etwas machen, oder?
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber das ist nur Verdachtdiagnose.
Um Diagnose zu bestätigen,
soll ich Ihnen zuerst körperlich untersuchen,
dann Blut abnehmen, gegebenenfalls
mitgewöhnlichen Verfahren,
vielleicht einen Bauch-Utaschall
oder Bauch-Röntgen.
Okay, ja, also machen Sie,
was Sie für notwendig haben.
Hauptsache, dass das wird besser.
Ich muss ja irgendwie wieder zu meiner Familie zurück.
Ja, nein.
Ja, wir geben alle bester, also,
machen Sie keine Sorge.
Sie sind eh nachher.
Gut.
Ja, okay.
Dankeschön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestärkt.
Ich denke auch.
Also, das war sehr vollständig.
Ja.
Was habe ich das Einzige, was ich doch auf meinem Zettel hatte?
War der dunkle Orin?
Und den haben Sie ganz zum Schluss noch nachgefragt.
Also wirklich krass, ja.
Gut.
Ich würde gerne wissen,
was sollten wir als Arzt,
den Patentin bei der
Alkohol-Anemdese
etwas sagen?
Was haben wir Reaktionen gemacht?
Ein Reaktion?
Also, wir haben das schon häufiger drüber gesprochen.
Erstens mal glaube ich,
dass in seltensten Fällen
irgendjemand Ihnen eine ehrliche Antwort gibt.
Ja, die Leute trinken viel mehr Alkohol,
als sie jemals sagen.
Ja.
Und, also, wenn Ihnen jemand sagt,
ich trinke jeden Tag eine halbe Flasche Weinbrand
abends noch Rotwein,
dann dürfen Sie natürlich nicht tot vom Schreibtisch fallen,
sondern Sie müssen sagen, oha, ja,
gut interessant, ja.
Ja, die Leute konsumieren
einfach Unmengen von Zigaretten und Alkohol.
Das ist so.
Ja.
Und die Lady hiermit,
ihren zwei, drei Gläsern seckt,
oder sechs Gläsern seckt in der Woche,
ist ja wahrscheinlich noch exquisit harmlos.
Aber so in Wahrheit,
in Wahrheit wird natürlich
unglaublich viel mehr getrunken.
Ja.
Und auch die Geschichte mit den Packiers,
wie viele Leute gibt es,
die sich wirklich eine Zigarette an der anderen anzünden
und die am Tag, also drei Packen Zigaretten durchziehen?
Ja.
Das ist nicht so selten.
Und irgendwo bin ich gewesen,
beim Einkaufen in der Einkaufsschlange,
da habe ich so gedacht,
oh, puh, da steht ja ein Aschenbecher neben mir, ja.
Also die Leute, ja,
die riechen natürlich aus jeder Pohre nach,
nach, nach Nikotin,
nach Rauch.
Ja, aber ich glaube,
Sie müssen versuchen, da einfach die Contes-Lancs zu wahren
und zu sagen, okay, ja gut, okay, ich notiere das.
Und gerade wenn jemand so akute Bauchschmerzen hat
oder akut irgendwelche Probleme hat,
ist natürlich auch nicht der Zeitpunkt zu sagen,
oh, wenn Sie mit dem Rauchen aufhören möchten,
oder wenn Sie lieber weniger können,
wir Ihnen durchaus helfen, ja.
Das ist zwar sehr nett gemeint, ja.
Aber ich denke mal, das ist der falsche Augenblick.
Das kann man irgendwann später mal machen,
wenn man sagt, hören Sie mal
mit Ihrem Nikotin-Konsum
oder mit Ihrem Alkohol-Konsum,
werden Sie mit dieser Krankheit niemals fertig, ja.
Dann ist der Zeitpunkt zu sagen,
wenn Sie ein akutes,
wenn Sie akuten Handlungsbedarf sehen,
oder wenn Sie meinen, Sie brauchen Unterstützung,
können wir Ihnen gerne helfen.
Aber ich glaube, in dieser Anfangssituation
ist das nicht der richtige Augenblick.
Noch? Ja.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage, Frau Haugen.
Was vergessen? Ja, Mensch. Ja, was denn?
Fühlen Sie sich viel Brit, oder?
Hat er gefragt? Ja.
Hat er gefragt und ich habe das verneint.
Okay, zweite Frage ist,
haben Sie gelbliche Veränderung der Augen oder Haut bemerkt?
Nein, das hat sie nicht bemerkt.
Sie hat eben nur den dumpfen Urin bemerkt.
Okay, danke Ihnen.
Können wir anfangen?
Ja, ich fähre es einmal.
Also, guten Abend, Frau Oberlin.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Ja, wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Also, Frau Roswita Hagen.
Sie ist 61 Jahre alt, 1,63 m groß und 80 kg schwer.
Hat sich bei uns wegen seit heute Vormittag
bestehende, krabartige epigastischen Schmerzen vorgestellt.
Die Schmerzen legen von 8 bis 9 von 10 auf eine Schmerzkala.
Und die Patientin berichtet,
dass die Schmerzen nach dem Verzehr von
rot-häufig-schinken-Käse,
also aufgetreten sind.
Und nach einer Stunde verzehrt.
Eine Stunde nach dem Verzehr.
Genau.
Und wichtig zu erwähnen,
dass die Patientin eine dunkle Urin bemerkt hat.
Seit mehreren Wochen.
Oh, mhm.
Und desweiteren klagte die Patientin
über 3-mal im Mesis.
Das Erbruch in der Erbar-Essen-Reste.
Und die Fragen nach FIBA,
Mixion und Defekation-Probleme
wurden verneint.
Und die einzige,
die einzige vegetative,
also an der vegetative Anäste
klagte die Patientin über Appetitlosigkeit.
Anvor Erkrankungen leidet die Patientin,
also bei der Patientin
ist keine Erkrankung bekannt.
Und vor 10 Jahren
wurde die Patientin eine Myo-Mectomie.
Und mit Alter 10 Jahren
eine Adenoidemie durchgeführt.
Okay.
Und die Patientin nehme
bei Bedarf Magnesium Tabletten.
Und bei der Patientin
eine Nikkele Allergie bekannt,
die sich Kontakt der Matitis äußert.
Ah, okay.
Die Nikotinkonsum-Wurdung verneint.
Sie trinkt 2, 3, 6,
und die Nikkele alle
mit Bein.
2, 3, 6,
Gläser oder Flaschen?
Gläser.
Und 1, 2,
was ich geschrieben habe,
habe ich nicht gut gelesen.
2, 3,
jetzt zur Woche.
1 bis 2.
Sie haben in der Woche 1 bis 2 Gläser.
Also 4 bis 6 Gläser.
Und?
Rogenkonsum-Wurdung verneint.
Sie ist gegen Corona
4 Mal geimpft.
Und gegen Ripe auch.
nicht genau, ob sie vollständig ist oder nicht. Sie besucht ihr Frauenarztin regelmäßig. Die
letzte Vorsorgeuntersuchung war unauffällig. Bei der Familienanalyse ergab sich, dass der Vater
an Apoplex gelitten hat und die Mutter an Diabetes Melitus leidet. Sie ist Einzelkind und sie arbeitet
in der Kunstkaliere und hat zwei gesunde Töchter. Also aufgrund der bisherigen Angaben und von einer
Diagnose. Also ich habe viele Vertragdiagnose deswegen. Ich muss eines sagen, gehe ich von einer
Parcretitis. In die Fernseher Diagnose kommen auch Colocholitis,
wahrscheinlich Panthizitis vielleicht und eine Renalcolytis. Um eine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
werde ich die Patientin körperlich untersuchen. Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung,
achte ich darauf, ob der Patient schmerzlos hat oder nicht. Also beide abtasten. Okay,
ja, Druckschmerzhaftigkeit. Und die Schmerzlokalisation werde ich überprüfen. Und worauf achten Sie noch?
Also die Farbe der Haut, auch überprüfen. Und bei der Laboruntersuchung werde ich Blutbild,
Entzündungparameter wie BSG-CRP, Leberwerte, ALT-AST, Bilübine und Indriktbilübine und
Pagreative Enzyme, Lipase und Amylase, werde ich kontrollieren. Und als eine
Bauchunterschale würde ich zuerst durchführen. Was erwarten Sie? Also zum Beispiel eine Kalenblaserwand,
vielleicht Verdigung werde ich feststellen. Und kann ich auch die, also neben Nierensteine
vielleicht oder Vergrößerung, vielleicht kann ich es sehen. Kann man sowas sehen, ja. Also das Bauchultraschall
wird jetzt einiges klären. Ja, gut. Freie Luft oder freie Flüssigkeit im Bauch kann ich auch
überkennen. Genau, ja. Gut, ja, dann bin ich gespannt. Also welche Untersuchungen würden
Unteraufstätten als Folgeuntersuchungen noch sich anschließen? Also gegebenenfalls, wenn der
Patient viele, also die Patientin, Patientin Blährungen hat, wer hat, hätte, könnte ich nicht gut mit
Unterauschall sehen. Erkennen, ja, bewerten. Dann brauche ich vielleicht eine MRT, die Parker
zu sehen oder die andere Organe zu bewölken. Ja, gut. Dann ja, dann starten Sie mal Ihre Untersuchungen
und halten Sie mich auf alle Fälle auf dem Laufenden, was für Ergebnisse rauskommen. Sie haben die
Patientin ja bestimmt stationär aufgenommen. Ja, stimmt. Sie haben hier, glaube ich, auch
schon etwas gegen die Schmerzen gegeben, ne? Hinter den Nösen habe ich etwas gegeben. Ja,
das geben Sie ihr noch? Also ich gebe auch einen Buskupan, vielleicht, dieser Kraft-
Spassmolitiskumpf, ne? Ja, genau. Ja, sehr gut. Okay, gut. Ja, dann schauen wir mal, was aus der
Frau Hagen wird. Ja, man merkt den Anästhesisten. Der hat gleich den Zugang gelegt. Das hat mir gut
gefallen. Ja, ja, das war, das war schön. Schöne Anamnese vollständig. Ich meine auch ein sehr
vollständiger Bericht. Das einzige Augenblick, das mir gefehlt hat, die, die ausgeprägte Nausea haben
Sie nicht erwähnt. Ja, ja. Und Sie haben gesagt, Defikation keine Probleme. Sie hat aber gesagt,
Sie haben schon seit längerer Zeit immer mal wieder Durchfall. Ja, gut. Also als echte Diagnose hat
die Patientin eine geilen Blasen- Entzündung, eine Colitis Citis. Das ist das, was hier im Beispiel
rausgekommen ist. Es ist ein Düsseldorferfall. Alle Düsseldorfer kennen ihn bis zum
Röse-Malihagen. Ja. Ihnen kann man ja nichts vormachen, Dr. Bundes. Ja. Gut. Am Anfang habe ich auch
Colitis Citis oder Colitis Citis gedacht, aber dann wegen diesen Alkoholkonsum und diese. Das ist aber
ja nicht viel. Also das ist ja echt nicht viel, was sie trinkt. Also zwei bis drei Gläser seckt
in einer Woche oder vier bis sechs Gläser sechstens in einer Woche ist tatsächlich, würde ich mal sagen,
noch harmlos. Ja. Aber wo ich, wo ich mir immer nicht im Klaren bin, Augenblick,
Gallenblase, Leber, rechts, ja das passt schon, ne. Ja, aber es gibt ja auch, es gibt ja für die
Galle irgendwie so, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, vier, vier F, die dafür sprechen,
dass jemand female? This. Sex sogar. Female, fat, fertile, fair, blond. Gravidatum. Ja,
fertile, also fruchtbar. Und, was gibt es noch? Haut, hell. Hell heutig. Ja. Also jedenfalls,
ne, das sind schon einige Punkte, die so für diese, für diese geilen Geschichte sprechen. Ja. Und
das war es dann eben auch. Ja. Und ja, also, was mir aufgefallen ist, sie sprechen sehr, sehr gut
Deutsch. Was ein bisschen fehlt, ich weiß nicht, wie man das, wie man das jetzt spontan verbessern
kann. Sie haben ein bisschen so eine eintönige Sprachmelodie. Das macht es manchmal schwer,
zuzuhören. Ich versuche das jetzt mal nachzumachen. Die Patientin hat sich heute bei uns vorgestellt,
wie ein Kolikartiger Oberbauchschmerz. Ja, also, wir lieben es ein bisschen dramatisch, ja. Die
Patientin hat sich mit kolikartigen Schmerzen bei uns vorgestellt. Ja, der dürfen so ein paar
ups and downs so in der Stimme kommen. Und es macht es leichter, sie zu verstehen. Ja. Und es ist
einfacher zuzuhören. Es ist nicht so ermüdend. Es ist natürlich auch schon spät, es kommt dazu. Aber
es ist wirklich, es ist wirklich für mich auffällig gewesen, sowohl bei den Fragen,
als auch bei dem Bericht, dass sie eigentlich stimmlich immer so auf einem ganz einheitlichen
Level waren. Wenn Sie mal reinhören in die Aufnahme, merken Sie es wahrscheinlich. Ja. Und
die sogenannten auf Englisch sich selbst. Ja, ja, okay. Also, wenn Sie reinhören, werden Sie
schmerzen. Und die Patientin selber ist ja eigentlich eher so eine Drama Queen, ne? Ja,
Schmerzen, Schmerzen. Und ja, und Sie haben die natürlich wunderbar ausgebremst, indem Sie ihr
gleich etwas gegen die Schmerzen gegeben haben. Wunderbar, sehr schön. Ja. Wann haben Sie Ihre
Prüfung? Also, im 16. Dezember. Oh, ist noch lange hin. Sie könnten morgen hingehen,
da kein Problem. Ja, gut. Okay. Ja, so viel für heute. Ja, vielen Dank. Ja, wir sehen uns am
Dienstag wieder. Ja. Dienstag.